It certainly raised a specter
in the back of people's minds.
And this he is,
um,
what,
what are the rules?
Who,
who gets punished when they fail and who
doesn't and what is too big to fail me?
Like I think you could reverse that.
So big failure is inevitable.
That's a really good rule of thumb.
Okay.
No.
Like I,
I think both the left and the right
haven't seen that cause the left things,
well big corporations
back and the right things,
big government bad.
And maybe you should just think big,
bad,
too many eggs in one basket.
So it goes against the
principle of diversification.
And so,
and I think there's
some real truth in this.
I think that as things get large,
they turned into cyclops,
let lumbering one,
I giant there,
they can't see worth a damn.
There's single minded which makes them
really narrow and they lumber around
stepping on things accidentally
until they fall off things,
you know?
And that's the right,
I think that's the right
model for a giant system.
That's why we have the image
of the giant site logs.
It's,
you know,
it's single mindedness turned
into gigantism and it's risky.
So should we bail out these big companies?
Okay.
There's something about that
that seems radically unfair.
So,
uh,
but I don't know what to do about that,
except to note that big in and of itself
is troublesome.